OK.
There is a disturbing new piece in The Atlantic
by Barton Gellman called The Election that
could break America.
This is red alert stuff.
This is not a rehearsal.
Okay.
This piece explains the plan that the Trump
campaign has put together to bypass election
results.
If Donald Trump loses, they have a plan for
how to subvert the election results.
If Joe Biden were to win and if we merely
ignore it, we're not going to be prepared.
So this is really the stuff of nightmares.
Now, I mean, explain the idea to you.
The idea is the following.
Trump choosing electors in battleground states,
regardless of who wins the states so that
they will vote for Donald Trump at the electors
convention.
OK, this is based on what some call a technicality.
Normally, the popular vote in a state determines
which electors go to D.C. to cast their ballots.
So if Joe Biden wins, Michigan, preselected
Democratic electors go to D.C. and they say
Michigan pledges our electoral votes for Joe
Biden.
The idea here is even if Biden wins Michigan,
some Republican strategists and lawyers are
saying even if Biden wins Michigan, Donald
Trump could say there was fraud in Michigan.
We are going to send the Republican electors
to D.C. instead of the Democratic electors,
even though supposedly Biden won Michigan,
because I believe that there was fraud.
That's the idea.
Now, the immediate reaction from a normal
person would be how the hell do you justify
it?
And indeed, the justification is fraud.
Their explanation would be, we believe.
There was broke voter fraud.
We don't really believe Biden won Michigan
as an example.
So because Trump actually won.
Trump is going to select Republican electors
to go to D.C. and represent Michigan.
The Atlantic explains that, quote, Trump would
ask state legislators to set aside the popular
vote and exercise their power to choose a
slate of electors directly.
The longer Trump succeeds in keeping the vote
count in doubt, the more pressure legislators
will feel to act before the safe harbor deadline
expires.
A Trump campaign legal adviser spoke to the
Atlantic for this story and said that the
goal would be for state legislatures to say
we've been given this constitutional power.
If they don't think the results of their state
are accurate or if they're willing to at least
suspend disbelief in order to help Trump,
they could say we are overriding the elector
choices and we're sending Republican electors
to Washington, D.C..
The chair of the Pennsylvania Republican Party,
Lawrence Tabby's, also spoke to the Atlantic
and said, quote, I've mentioned it to them
and I hope they're thinking about it, too.
Referring to this strategy, they are looking
at these strategies.
This is just one idea we've talked.
You know, the more pedestrian and obvious
ideas are having an army of lawyers descend
on states at midnight on November 3rd.
Well, technically, it would be midnight, November
4th at the end of Election Day.
And the idea of the Red Mirage scenario would
be because of early in-person voting by Trump
voters at midnight at the end of Election
Day.
Trump might have a slight lead in some states.
However, if all the absentee ballots were
to be counted, those leads might evaporate
in favor of Joe Biden.
The idea would be you have lawyers descend
on states at midnight to say stop counting
absentee ballots, making different legal arguments
in different states.
So this is not a joke.
They are prepared.
I've said it before.
If Trump loses, I do believe he will eventually
leave.
But here are ways he can try to claim he didn't
actually lose either by preventing votes from
being counted.
Claiming he won and sending in different electors.
Trump's legal teams are laying the groundwork
for all of these strategies now.
We've read that Joe Biden and the Democratic
Party are also lawyering up.
Are they going to be ready?
And one of the difficulties is when you're
playing offense.
You only need to come up with one strategy
the defense isn't prepared for and deploy
it.
When you're playing defense, you have to anticipate
every strategy in order to be prepared for
it.
And that's why this is so dangerous.
What if it's simply not definitive?
Come Election Day, Will Julian Zelizer, who
teaches history and public affairs at Princeton,
says to the Atlantic that, quote, We are not
prepared for this at all.
We talk about it, some worry about it, and
we imagine what it would be.
But few people have actual answers to what
happens if the machinery of democracy is used
to prevent a legitimate resolution to the
election.
Our democracy would be dead if Trump succeeds
at this.
If we fail, this is what happens.
Republicans are making it clear they don't
win by democracy.
They will win despite democracy, unable to
subvert democracy.
As David Frum said, if conservatives become
convinced that they cannot win democratically,
they will abandon conservatism and they will
reject democracy.
And by the way, it is not lost on me that
this is part of why they want to rush to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
That could end up being a factor.
We are really up against it here.
And it is just as appalling how Republicans
supporters, Republican voters are so entrenched
in their team sport mentality that they were,
by and large, are standing by as Donald Trump
develops these strategies.
As long as they reject the Libs.
Right, that's the point.
They will accept blatant corruption.
They will stand aside as democratic values,
not not capital D. Lowercase.
The democratic values are dismantled and they
will let Trump do whatever the hell he wants.
We are up against it.
My friends, let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman.